both Ukraine and Russia have claimed
that hundreds of enemy troops have been
killed over the past 24 hours in the
battle for bakmut a Ukrainian military
spokesperson said 221 Pro Moscow troops
were killed and more than 300 wound did
meanwhile Russia's defense Ministries
said up to 210 Ukrainian soldiers were
killed in the broader Donetsk part of
the front line well joining us now is a
retired Air Vice Marshal Sean Bell who
is with us a very good afternoon to you
so what's the significance of both these
sides claiming that so many casualties
in this battle Yeah it's highly unusual
isn't it but if we look at let's look at
the sort of overall picture at the
moment there's over 1200 miles of Front
Line although we'll come back to back
moot that there is fighting all the way
along this front line down in Harrison
down to the Southwest there the Russians
are firing from the east side of the
deeper River into house and overnight
there were three innocent civilians
going shopping that were killed and also
from zapparicha to validar here although
there's no movement on the front line
the Russians are digging in there's
loads of shelling backwards and forwards
in there but as you say the main
fighting here really is around back move
we've been talking about this last six
months huge casualty figures as part of
the Russian offensive and if we zoom in
at the moment just have a quick look at
the the city itself of that moot um the
river the bahamuta river through here
now it looks like Russia occupies the
Eastern side the ukrainians on the
western side but it's slightly more
complicated than that because the
Russians doing a pinch around the top
and the bottom aiming to try to cut off
this resupply route the 504 down to the
um down to the Southwest as you say the
one strange thing about this is although
we've been reporting huge casualties
both sides don't normally account
they're talking about 220 odd deaths
over the last 24 hours it looks likely
that Russia are doing this for their
domestic audience they know full well
they've taken huge casualties and I'll
be wanting to demonstrate that they can
also inflict the same on Ukraine but
Ukraine has to be really careful here to
getting dragged into a war of attrition
because the issue here is Russia is a
much larger country than Ukraine it's
got significantly more resources is
significant more manpower and equipment
and it's pretty clear that Putin doesn't
care about the loss of human life so
Russia wants to drag Ukraine into a war
of attrition which Russia will know it
can win now in the first world war we
had massive Wars of attrition in the
west at the end of that didn't have the
appetite for those sorts of casualties
again so he developed this maneuver
Warfare where he used technology to try
to limit number of casualties you have
and of course the West weapons have
proven a completely decisive so far in
the battle the challenge for the West
though or the Social Security of
zelinski is this battle is personal so
let's look at back moved from that
strategic perspective a military
perspective this is not a significant
objective but it's become highly
symbolic between both solensky and
President Putin and the challenge
therefore even U.S Secretary of Defense
Lloyd Austin and the U.S military using
diplomatic language have said to
president zlinski you probably need to
be pulling your forces out of batmooton
saving them for another day whereas
actually president zlinski has done
entirely the opposite he's put forces in
there now to be clear from military
perspective there's no right answer here
but the huge risk is that President
zlinsky risk is using a lot of seasonal
Warriors which he needs for the battles
to come we mentioned about resources our
Ukraine needs a lot more I guess for the
battles to come notably this spring
offensive which we've heard quite a bit
about in recent weeks we have now both
sides how you remember that the Russians
have mobilized 300 000 soldiers they
seem to got through quite a lot of that
they haven't got the training capacity
to do another 300 000 because it's their
annual cycle of getting their uh con uh
conscripts in as well there's about 400
000 a year of those and besides that
would generate quantity not quality and
we've already seen what happens on the
battlefield but Ukraine is also facing
that same challenge it's also having
huge casualties they need to train
Replacements as well and we've heard
that the ukrainians are training 28 000
uh folks which they're calling their
offensive guard their aim will be to
help liberate uh Ukraine it's looking as
if they'll be the backup Force following
the Army in and they will do the mopping
up Opera operation afterwards now
although the International Community is
helping a lot with the training task
this is still going to generate quantity
not quality and unless Ukraine for this
forthcoming offensive can can maintain
some of its seasoned campaigners the
danger is it ends up being lots of
inexperienced Soldiers the Russian
experience has just showed what a price
you pay for inexperience on the
battlefield goodness all right Sean
thank you for that